il futuro è
tanto connessione
azione esiste un luogo nel tempo ai
margini della memoria che forma una
ripida spiaggia crollata in alto da
robusti pensieri in questo luogo mi sono
recato sono i calanchi di basilicata
calanchi che si trovano all'interno del
territorio di pisticci e sono
assolutamente unplugged unplugged sta
per disconnesso staccato scollegato in
un certo senso inarrivabile impervio e i
calanchi sono esattamente un luogo
unplugged una una parola in
controtendenza lasciatevi affascinare
ogni tanto dalle controtendenze c'è la
connessione è di certo quello a cui
tendiamo oggi a tutti gli effetti e in
ogni espressione ma ogni tendenza
potente sottintende una controtendenza e
unplugged è una controtendenza
importante per questa esperienza che
vanno a raccontarvi i calanchi sono un
deserto d'argilla sono un luogo poco
ospitale per l'essere umano non
collegato da strade ben realizzate non
servito da corrente elettrica da acqua e
parte sono zone agricole in parte sono
zone assolutamente desertiche e
abbandonare a volte luogo di pascolo
franchi
mi regalano una esperienza particolare
questo contatto con questa materia prima
straordinaria che el'argilla argilla il
suono stesso di questa parola mi ha
portato una piccola vertigine è sono
luoghi che conosco da quando sono
bambino sono luoghi
da me usati per sentirmi anche lontano
da casa pur rimanendo nel sul posto in
un certo senso è infatti chi visita i
calanchi sente miglioramenti di essere
molti dicono è un paesaggio lunare
io dico che extraterrestre
nel senso che intendiamo anche extra
large ma molto largo molto terrestre e
la terra è anche questo
forse è simile alla luna o forse è come
prima
prima di essere luna e terra e questa
argilla ci ha comunicato una sede le
forme di questa pasta meravigliosa ci
fanno sentire che la terra asset e la
terra si crepa si corruga diventa come
un un pachiderma una pelle di elefante
bellissimo toccare e sentire come
sgretolando si crea un solo di pioggia
che quell'acqua che manca in quel
momento lì e ho pensato di dover fare
qualcosa per rendere fertile questo
deserto
di certo la mano dell'uomo attraverso
l'agricoltura ha fatto una parte perché
non innaffiare d'arte questi luoghi è un
luogo però sconnesso abbiamo pensato di
portarci il teatro ci siamo ci siamo
impelagati in una idea che al solo
l'inizio
conteneva delle sfide molto molto delle
soluzioni
diciamo non immediate quindi decidendo
di portare il teatro in questi luoghi ci
troviamo anche di fronte a una serie di
problematiche e dovremmo portare la
corrente dovremmo portare sfrutto
strutture dovremo portare sedute
dovranno portare spalti dovremmo portare
amplificazione acustica
è tutto molto difficile le strade non
sono esattamente praticabili dovremo
anche portare il pubblico tutto sommato
è in qualche modo dovrebbe arrivare per
fruire dell'opera dark c costringiamo ad
un gesto artistico estremo decidiamo di
non utilizzare nessuna connessione non
utilizziamo una corrente elettrica per
amplificare per illuminare non
utilizziamo gruppi elettrogeni non
utilizziamo grandi fari non utilizzano
strumenti che hanno bisogno di un
amplificazione
facciamo in modo da negarci tutte queste
possibilità che sono una soluzione ma
diventano un altro problema in realtà ci
viene incontro una visione comune nell
incontro con il regista matteo tarasco
che visita questi luoghi si innamora e
propongo a lui di essere di gestire una
residenza artistica per sette attrici
una connazionale rispondono in 200 e
attrici sosteniamo come l'evento lo
sosteniamo con il finanziamento delle
persone con il singolo che in qualche
modo sostiene l'evento acquistando una
sottoscrizione
mettiamo in scena le baccanti devo dire
un testo dalla forza indescrivibile che
si sposa in una maniera mistica con gli
spazi questo è il risultato baccanti
illuminato solo dalla luce del fuoco e
riscaldato dai cuori di 500 persone che
in uno degli spettacoli è stato presente
riempiendo le comodissime sedute in
paglia di cui era costituita una platea
e succede questa cosa straordinaria in
realtà il charango e
sembra molto ospitale raccontato in
questo modo la madre terra si fa
matrigna a volte e non ci fa mancare
degli acquazzoni terribili 180 mm in 12
ore cioè oltre il 50 per cento di quello
che accade in un anno da queste parti
nei calanchi dove una goccia d'acqua
diventa una fiumana di fango
pensate una pioggia indescrivibile che
cosa ha potuto creare tra le varie
difficoltà ci ha creato una grande
voglia di sfidare ulteriormente la
natura del calanco lui forse non ci
vuole forse ci vuole sono battezzare se
questo è il risultato
lo prendiamo con un battesimo quello di
dioniso quello del calanco abbiamo anche
coinvolto altri artisti all'interno di
questo percorso pensando di lavorare
sempre sulla materia prima argilla e
quindi abbiamo manipolato realmente una
parte di calanco dalle mani sapienti di
annamaria pagliai che ha proposto una
sua versione dell'attaccante è un
progetto che poi andato anche avanti nel
tempo e che incontrando il fuoco ha
prodotto nelle edizioni successive di
teatro dei calanchi questo è il nome del
parto del calanco
questa iniziativa delle donne d'argilla
che venivano illuminate dalla luce del
fuoco il fuoco è un grande fratello
dell'argilla
perché mentre lei è molto fragile ed è
modesta per certi aspetti prima di
incontrare il fuoco una volta accaduto
questo magico incontro l'argilla si fa
tosta l'argilla si fa resistente diventa
ceramica e la manipolazione dell'argilla
morbida di questa pasta ci dà la
possibilità di declinare la materia
prima in un altro modo e ci consente
anche di risolvere un altro problema
perché eravamo lì nel calano di fronte a
500 persone con due ettari di teatro
praticamente le attrici che non erano in
proscenio come siamo qui a distanza
ravvicinata ma erano a diverse decine di
metri e disposte in su questo ripido
calanco di amplificare la voce delle
attrici abbiamo immaginato di trovare
una soluzione dell'argilla stessa ci
viene in soccorso un cassetto chiuso
forse dieci anni prima
dentro il quale c'era un esperimento che
è realizzato proprio con le mani di
questo artigiano che si chiama feltrin
onorati collega di annamaria pagliari e
realizza abbiamo realizzato un vaso
sonoro in una visita al museo degli
strumenti musicali di berlino ci
imbattiamo in una mostra specifica degli
strumenti musicali in ceramica
riconosciamo questo oggetto ci
incuriosisce
si ritorna nella nostra terra e lo si fa
si manipolano si provano si mette nel
cassetto aperto questo cassetto questo
caso ci regala una soluzione sono io il
megafono sono io lo strumento musicale
che le attrici possono maneggiare per
invocare dioniso nel del dramma delle
vacanze e così diventa strumento
musicale
l'argilla la ceramica diventa sonora
questa è la forma del nostro mega foto
non è una vera e propria dimensione una
scoperta ma in epoca e riconoscenza
liquida il tutto si scopre e poco si
inventa è uno strumento che ha origine
africana a un'altra forma si chiama udu
con due e una di centrale e la sua
scoperta nell'occidente è data da un
archeologo statunitense frank giorgini
probabilmente di origine italiana che
porta questo reperto ritrovato in
nigeria
dalle nostre parti lo amplia lo studio
noi ci conviviamo la forma di questo
oggetto di questo strumento pensando di
regalargli un impugnatura e una
variabilità nella nel suono regalato il
2 fori ma e vi farò vedere come funziona
due fori attraverso i quali stimolare
l'aria che c'è all'interno e la
superficie dello strumento udu e
diciamola l'emulazione sonora del nome
originale di questo strumento
con queste doppie doppie o con una di
centrare che riproducono in sostanza lo
stesso lo stesso tipo di suono rimane
invariata la parola tant'è che udu
significa vaso e significa anche pace
contiene dei messaggi assolutamente
positivi lo costruiamo in tre versioni
ridisegnato una grossa una media una
piccola anche bianco filtriamo le nostre
arginare facciamo uscire fuori una pasta
ancora più nobile che diventa che regala
nuove sfumature al nostro strumento
accade che io pongo una domanda ma sono
un teatrante un amante della cultura
classica antica e mi può questa domanda
è possibile che nella nostra cultura di
qua del mediterraneo e con tutta la
tecnologia legata alla c'erano
questo strumento non è giunto da queste
parti mi diverto a creare dei fake
essenzialmente sono finti è un graffito
potete vedere da qualche parte degli
hutu contenuti nelle mani dei nostri
antichissimi progenitori
potete vederlo anche nelle mani di un
famoso dio egizio e potete trovarlo
addirittura nelle mani delle pale street
e nei mosaici di piazza armerina e
qualche archeologo c'è cascato la
disattenzione non si legge magari un
testo un post e di fronte a una di
queste non avevo mai visto non ero mai
accorto di questa cosa ma che cosa
fantastico lì a convincerlo che era una
bugia e non è stato semplice convincere
che fosse una un grande gioco teatro dei
calanchi forte di questa ceramica di
questa argilla quindi di questa argilla
che si fa più dura e più forte riesce a
sostenere questa iniziativa continua nel
tempo ed aumenta la partecipazione di
queste di questi sottoscrittori delle
persone che liberamente scelgono di
sostenere dando un gettone l'iniziativa
artistica e tutto il progetto si compone
di altre nuove esperienze altri inserti
teatrali nuovi coinvolgimenti per nuove
sette attrici l'anno il secondo anno di
teatro dei calanchi va in scena medea le
idee al plurale medea e il dramma antico
con un composito autorale sempre diretto
dal regista matteo tarasco sempre sette
voci di donna per lo stesso personaggio
è sempre più suggestivo lavorare con il
calanco e lavorare sul calanco e fare in
modo che il calanco t link a essere
attore sul calanco è una esperienza
indimenticabile e potentissima
gli attori di teatro lab è un piccolo
laboratorio fondato qualche tempo fa
pisticci all'interno di un centro
culturale insieme a cirkus e ancora vive
centro d'iniziativa ricerca della futura
lo spettacolo sforna o meglio coltiva
nell'intimo questa passione per l'arte
scenica e forma in mezza basilicata a
diverse diverse persone dell'arte
scenica teatro lab diventa gli alieni
teatro lab fanno la loro prima
esperienza sulla scena cruda e poco
ospitale dei calanchi si recita a piedi
nudi e non è una cosa semplice e si
recita si si recita quest'anno questa
volta anche di giorno
quindi utilizzando un fuoco che un po
più lontano da quello che accenderanno
direttamente ai piedi delle attrici che
il sole l'anno scorso la terza edizione
di teatro lab da in scena odissea tutta
di giorno e solamente gestita da dagli
allievi del teatro lab un laboratorio
che esce fuori dai confini del suo
centro culturale e tocca a 500 in
basilicata un la storia delle storie
possiamo dire l'odissea che prende vita
in gran parte della storia viene
raccontata nel mario a che fare con il
mare ma prende vita in questo deserto
dei calanchi che però contiene ancora il
sapore del mare perché se scaviamo poco
poco tra le rughe di quella argilla
troveremo dei reperti di qualche milione
di anni fa dei fossili ccc che ci
raccontano di come questo è stato anche
un fondale marino di come forse quella
nave di ulisse abbia ecco così trovato
lì approdo
oggi pensando di rievocare una storia
che non è immortale che contiene ancora
il suo valore
voglio chiudere con questa immagine che
l'immagine che ha ispirato tutto il
progetto questa è una mammella è una
mammella d'argilla
si chiamano così i calanchi assumono
queste forme e ti danno il sapore della
mamma un calanco che crea che genera
argilla madre marge la matrigna e large
hill a volte si fa anche musica
[Musica]
[Applauso]